well guys I have for more reviews left
to do in my David Fincher series I
promise you guys that I would review
every single David Fincher film leading
up to GaN girl before gone girl and I'm
seeing that movie tomorrow night so I
got a lot of work to do tonight pretty
soon after this review is up I'm going
to have to you guys Curious Case of
Benjamin Button the social network and
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo let's
get started with Zodiac zodiac in my
opinion is David Fincher's most
underrated film and it just might
actually be my favorite of his you see
where seven might just be the best
fictional serial killer film ever made I
think zodiac is the best factual one
ever made this movies about the
real-life Zodiac killings that are still
unsolved to this day that took place
that baffled police detectives and
newspaper journalists all over the world
it's about the detectives that are
trying to solve the case and one
newspaper journalist who is absolutely
obsessed with it if you watch the
making-of documentary of this movie on
the Blu ray it's astounding the level of
detail that David Fincher and the people
working on this film went to recreate
the crime scenes the look of the scenes
the way the bodies were situated the
time the date the clothing that the
victims war was even recreated and
that's one of the things about zodiac
that makes it so much more interesting
to me because it is a real-life event
that took place in the level of detail
that they went to to recreate these
events really makes it even more
frightening c7 is a scary movie you
watch that movie and is disturbing but
it is fiction when you watch zodiac and
then you do the research it becomes way
more frightening than seven is because
you understand that these events took
place and it also kind of gets in your
head I can tell you that every time I
watch zodiac I actually become a little
bit obsessed with the case every time I
watch the movie I go and look up if
there's any new findings or any new
thoughts on the case it does that to
your brain Jake Gyllenhaal gives one of
his best performances as Robert
gray-smith a cartoonist who becomes
obsessed with the case and through his
obsession myself as a viewer every time
I watch this movie I want to go look up
stuff about this movie it gets into your
head
this is a very long movie it's almost
three hours long and yet it is perfectly
crap
and constructed to the point where this
movie never drags for me not once there
isn't a scene in this movie or a section
of this film that I think is slow and a
lot of that is due to the Magnificent
editing this is one of the best edited
films you can watch particularly look
for a scene in which Robert Downey jr.
is reading one of the zodiac letters
while lighting a cigarette while it's
intercut with other events are taking
place it's mesmerizing also David
Fincher purposefully had the actors read
a lot of their dialogue faster than they
normally would have so that the runtime
didn't get stretched too long this guy
is smart this guy is a filmmaking genius
and this is one of his best films in my
opinion Mark Ruffalo plays a detective
who's trying to solve this case and he
is also becoming obsessed as well as
Robert Downey jr. who is a news reporter
who is also trying to solve the case and
one of the things that zodiac as a film
does so well is portray the intense
obsession and the desire to try to find
out more information and to solve this
case and what it did to affect so many
different people from Mark Ruffalo's
detective Jake Gyllenhaal's cartoonist
and Robert Downey jr. news reporter all
three of these guys are absolutely
knee-deep in this case and once they
start to drown in it you really start to
see how this case had such an effect on
so many different people zodiac is a
perfectly constructed movie I think it's
one of the best directed movies ever
made
I think it's David Fincher's most
underrated film by far it is one of my
all-time favorite movies and I gotta
give zodiac and a plus cuz if you have
not checked out this disturbing
retelling of real-life accounts you have
got to check out zodiac it is one of my
favorite movies and I think it's one of
David Fincher's best if not his best so
I'm gonna be bringing my review for
Curious Case of Benjamin Button your
guys way very soon look forward to that
it's going to be up in just a couple
hours I hope you guys check that out and
as always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes